[موسيقى]
معنا في الجمعه كل يوم جمعه نتجمع في
مواقف مدخل المطاعم ان شاء الله لقدام
يكون عندنا مصاري
من جايبين خاص
[تصفيق]
بردو يعني بحفز اصحاب الايمن لاصدقائهم
يعني ممكن يقتل اليدين لكن عنده مهاره
عاليه جدا من المؤثرين جدا حتى ممكن صورته
على حساب الرسمي برضو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الرياض يعني ممكن في حياه كل زوج فينا
يعني انا برضه
وقدمت بر
[موسيقى]
ضه
دي
بساحه السودان
اللي فيه الاشعه
وعملت فيديو اخيرا في السودان نزلت اللعبه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فيها سياحه عالميه تنافس عالميا ده نزلته
الليله انا ممكن اعمل كارت عايز 200 نفر
يشوفوه ممكن اغلبه
[موسيقى]
السودان بصوره
فعايز اقول لكم انه انا ان شاء الله انشر
تدخل في كل السولاية وبتمنى برضه ما تكون
بس يعني الناس تكبر رياضية
المفروض الناس كلها تكون رياضه في حياتها
لانه رياضه صراحه
العقل السليم القسم السليم
[تصفيق]
بالنسبه لعيابه في ناس بالنسبه لها رياضه
الناس
مختلفه يكون
رياضيه لكن احنا ممكن الناس فينا نجيب
ادوات مثلا
تيشير وشفت
بالنسبه لنا الشعب السوداني انا
اعرف رياضه
ما
بعرف الحمد لله
مشاكل
فعلى صراحه ما عايز اطول عليكم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]